let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
all topics and questions welcome we'll
go to our first caller from the 2 4 0
area code caller and 2 4 0 introduce
yourself and tell us what's on your mind
today
oh hello I'm Patrick dang okay I'm
Patrick tag and I am a.m. and I am a
serving 2 year old who's really been
interested in politics for the past few
months and especially thoughts unsex
election I believe I've seen that arm
that the Democrats are really divided
between either the establishment or the
or the progressive values so I mean I
was thinking of living life and if I
could try and maybe be chopped in 2020
if everywhere to Thailand and I'll still
get maybe we can get like an outsider
someone kind of kungfu
person who's been involved in politics
but could come in like child and like
get some labels so I mean always taking
over - that may be a CBS anchor stock of
the Quebec Atlantic but offers
powerfully the lockups well listen I
don't know about that specifically but I
think you bring up an interesting idea
which is is there some progressive
equivalent to Donald Trump not in terms
of incompetence but in terms of appeal
as an outsider and I think it's an
interesting question because on the one
hand
why couldn't you replicate some aspects
of Trump on the Left path and yet much
of what made Trump popular are the types
of values and characteristics that
fundamentally make him completely off
putting two progresses I'm just weary of
getting involved in these celebrity
showdowns I know the rock Dwayne Johnson
has floated the idea of running as well
as Mark Cuban yeah let's just keep these
rich billionaire celebrity types out of
this
it's an interesting way of way of
thinking about it yeah I want to think
more about that Patrick I also for me
it's just way too early to be talking
about 2020 presidential because we've
got listen Democrats are in for a rude
awakening in 2018 if they can't get a
platform together that will actually be
progressive
so very very interesting question I
appreciate the call and we will see what
ultimately happens in 2018 and then we
can talk beyond that